from traveling the world and meeting
people from you know from very different
walks of life
it's opened my eyes in a beautiful way
to understanding
um that there's a lot more to understand
there's if there's a faith that i don't
understand i long to understand it as
best i can
um and i think it's it's really allowed
me to
to to seek truth and not just belief
if you could if you can appreciate the
truth of
appreciating truth um and rather than
if if you you know appreciate the truth
about this faith
then that counters your own faith
as long like that's that's where things
in my opinion
you know you get the hiccup and i i do
also believe we are seeking truth in
in as just as humans as people right
um and and there are so many truths
in in all of that this podcast exists
because i love talking to people and i
love going deep the purpose is
to plant seeds of inspiration we
enter a space of vulnerability and
relatability
and what you realize is that we are so
much more alike than we are different to
quote ramdas
we're all just walking each other home
and this show
is just one step i'm danica patrick and
i'm pretty intense
on the show today is hunter hayes he's a
absolutely adorable deep fascinating
self-reflective human being that has
really
used music to learn about himself to
process things and you know for me
that's the coolest thing about an artist
is when you really
when you hear those stories and it just
makes the
music so much more meaningful and that's
probably also why
someone is so popular why someone has
resonance is because it's coming from
that
space of being truthful and vulnerable
so
i hope you enjoy this interview today i
sure did he's just like such a doll
and um excited for what's to come from
here on out from hunter hayes
so nice to meet you i uh listen to your
music for so long
so nice well i appreciate that thank you
so much did you ever go to
did you ever go to a nascar race like
were you ever asked to perform or
anything
i did i got to uh i got to sing the
national anthem
um no sorry i did not see the nation
what am i talking about no i got to do a
performance
um we could do two actually i got to
wave the flag at the beginning of the
race was pretty pretty dope
was not prepared for how loud or like
what happens at the beginning of a race
like the amount of
like debris coming off the track it was
it was that was quite an experience
it's a dirty job
yeah i did i went and saw you in chicago
when you were uh
touring with um carrie underwood
oh nice okay yeah you know okay
nice yeah i'm trying to remember i can't
remember that specific
show it was years ago that was probably
2012.
2012 yeah yeah that was a crazy year we
did
i think 95 shows on that tour total it
was insane
yeah that was a it was a crazy intense
tour
because like you know like we're really
spoiled in nashville because we can tour
on weekends and like we can do thursdays
friday saturdays
and that was a tour that was like three
shows on
one day off three shows one day off it
was like solid booked through and i
hadn't experienced that until that point
i was spoiled like
i had entered my professional touring
career
i was like yeah we'll do three shows a
week maximum four four shows a week we
were doing
you know almost six five six shows at
least a week and it was just non-stop
for like six months it was a lot there's
a lot i was
i learned a lot about touring on that
tour the most about toronto
tour like what well just how to sustain
how to be
how to make it sustainable like i love
playing i love performing i love doing
what i do
um and again i was used to doing it on
the weekend so i always had like a
sunday and monday and a tuesday to sort
of like recuperate and
and take care of myself which i honestly
i'm still learning how to take care of
myself i still don't know how to do that
um but on that tour i learned a lot
about like how to
how to really honestly have a day off
and what i should do on a day off
because
typically on days off i i do some other
form of music i end up working anyway
because i love what i do like it's not
like it's not it's not
draining but i think i realized that i
had to really take advantage of days
off and like go on road trips and go on
trips by myself and things like that and
really properly recharge
you know um so
i feel like of all industries affected
in the last year
like music has been a huge one
especially obviously from the aspect of
performing
so do you feel like you learned even
more in the last year
with rick like taking care of yourself
and i know you said you're still working
on it i mean aren't we all but
um but did you learn anything else
about ways that you can better take care
of yourself so that perhaps
you know world tour coming up exactly
yeah i think it's the first time i've
actually sat down and really
realized touring is so many good things
for me that i i charge on that so much
it
fills my soul in a lot of different ways
there's the travel aspect
there's i get to do what i love like i
get to play music and i get to actually
connect with
people i get to see what we've done in a
vacuum
how it how it connects with human beings
and in person i
read their reaction when they're singing
you know a song with you on
that's you can feel that you can um and
you can
it just lifts you in such a big way it
just fills your tank and also like
i got spoiled i didn't realize how much
of a deal this was but i got spoiled
i was with like-minded people we're on a
bus with 12 people i'm with like-minded
people every night i'm going out to my
favorite bar which is the front lounge
of the bus every night and hanging out
with my favorite people after the show
there's so many elements of touring that
um i think i'm i'm
well number one i'm grateful for but i'm
also grateful for the lesson that
that i've learned in the last year which
is how how much
i love what i do and how much i love
being on the road and how important that
is for me and it's not just
you know it's not about attention or um
or just you know making a buck being on
the road it's
it's still a passion of mine and i'm
really grateful that
i've gotten to sort of see it while
being without it
you know and and and really sit down and
and
become aware of the things that are good
for me and also become aware of the
things that when i do go back on the
on the road things that i um
that i could probably do without or or
things i should
change about my daily routine and um
and you know etc etc and and there's
just you know even separate of the road
just yeah how to be a human
how to you know i i i think i
threw myself into work when i realized
we weren't gonna tour for a while like
i was like all right i'll make an album
i'll finish the album i've been working
on for
two three years um and i would do that
until you know four o'clock in the
morning and i'd run myself into the
ground i still do it
i'd still run myself into the ground
yeah oh you love what you do
do you feel like it gave like the album
sort of um
sort of migrated a little bit out of
country and into this new you've
i think you've been in la more often
like do you feel like the sound
change too like was that part of this
transformation
a bit yeah well i you know my son's
never been purely one
thing i think if i've if i've ever if
i've ever had a struggle it's been that
i don't
just fit in in one place uh and i think
this was the year that i finally stopped
seeing that as a struggle and seeing
that as an advantage and seeing yeah
that's a good thing and i
i've always felt like it was a good
thing and i've always instinctually
known that i think
it can come at a challenge when you're
when you're
asked to label yourself as one thing
um and i think this year was just the
year that i said well i don't really
have to
and and i think people are people are
still gonna get what i do and people are
still gonna
um dig it especially if i include more
of the things that i love in the music
that i make if i don't
try to edit it out based on
my understanding of other people's
expectations but i just give them
you know all of the influences that i
love if i put all of it together in a
project
um and and spending more time in la was
definitely part of that
that was something that was both
calculated and non-calculated we
honestly it started purely as
let's get an airbnb if we're gonna if
i'm gonna work
you know and so hard on an album
let's go to a really scenic place you
know we have a self-sufficient team
i was kind of like let's all be
somewhere we really want to be
um and that turned into me getting a
real estate agent and me
you know acquiring this little studio
compound um
because i just there's a lot of people i
love working with out there i love being
out there
um i've still got a place in nashville
and i kind of split my time between the
two but
i think being out there also just like
it was a you know a scenery change it
was a visual change and every day that i
woke up i was in
in this new place and um and it allowed
me to
to undo those filters and and really
include
the whole the rest of the story well of
course i'm going to ask what is that
but you said it changed the scenery but
the scenery changes your emotions and
your feeling
and so i'm curious about what those
things were
that changed as a result of seeing
things visually different
out your window yeah well you know
or how did you see yourself differently
i saw myself differently
the the limiting beliefs that i think i
had that i had
um maybe i can't include
all of the other genres that i love or
maybe i can't do certain things with my
musical production
um i also think writing-wise it helped
tremendously
and it also helped too that i was
working with like different producers
and different
people in different
[Music]
sort of job titles i love producing and
for some reason i had
told myself that i couldn't i couldn't
produce my own music
and in all actuality i really enjoy that
part of the process
i love collaboration and i think i had
to learn
um where i am learning
that you know collaborations don't all
have to look the same
and you know in the past you know
certain people who do certain
tasks in the in the order of making
music
it's been always very linear and i think
i had to break the line and just say no
i like
i like being involved in this part and
then i like giving it away and then i
like being involved in this part
and just learning where where my
strengths play into what i love to do
um it's not that i have to do all of one
thing or all of
the the other thing i enjoy the
collaboration and i enjoy
um sort of the tag team effort of it so
that was one thing that i i learned from
being out there and working with people
out there
and also just working on my own music
you know i wasn't looking at a wall
um the same wall working on on
production anymore i had
at a window with a view of the mountains
and i just felt like i was in this super
scenic like retreat
so it sort of felt like i was on
vacation making the album
which which undoes he's making like a
kenny chesney like
beach chair kind of an album now
yeah not necessarily but and it also
allowed me to fall in love with
you know there's a lot of parts of of
los angeles that have a very historic
place in music making i can't tell you
how many times i've watched the you know
sound city documentary and things like
that
um also allowed me to go back to
i really like old music i say old music
yeah
i mean you know whatever i like older
music i love stuff that was made in
certain era it's because
those eras were full of instrumentation
that is timeless to me that
doesn't ever get old we saw it this year
one of my favorite albums of all time
got another swing at life this year
because somebody posted a tick tock
on a freaking skateboard singing you
know a fleetwood back song and then all
of a sudden everybody was paying
attention to my favorite mac one of my
top three all-time favorite albums was
was on like a spotify playlist like
freaking like whatever it was it was on
this like super popular playlist that i
listen to all the time
but here was this super dope old sound
that actually still
sounds new and fresh so i think i just
reconnected with that too like i want to
make music that sounds timeless and
doesn't
just follow trends or just study what's
working and apply that
um i think you already have done that i
feel like i've talked to a lot of
artists and i find it to be such a
redeeming quality within an artist
whether it be
like i talked to moby um mclemore
like some of these guys where you can't
like you it's hard to even put your
finger on exactly what the genre is
because
you're creating your own which to me
says it's
really you're really accessing it from
spirit or from your um your truth
or who you are and that is not something
that's quantifiable that's not
boxable it just is what it is and so
i i i i admire you for sticking with
that and in fact even like
going in deeper have there been aspects
of the going in deeper that have felt
really uncomfortable yeah for sure
i mean you have to uh honestly last
night one of
one of my friends had a brilliant quote
i don't know if you heard this but
he said you know if you if you want to
have massive success you also have to
have a massive trash can
it's a ridiculous statement but it's so
true like you have to be
my my ratio is like 100 songs to get 10
that consistently it doesn't matter
like i it doesn't matter that i'm
learning how to make
better music or learning how to access
that thing
quicker or more efficiently or be more
present
i'm still going to need to write like
three songs to get the point across and
get to the place where and sometimes
it's the first song sometimes you end up
tossing everything that happens after
because you think you can do it better
and then you realize you already did it
more you know
honest um so i think that
you know there's scary stuff it's been
um
trying things and
you know knowing full well that i mean
anything outside of the
i know that this is what people are
expecting from me anything outside of
that is scary
and um and i can't tell you how many
songs i've i've written and
fully produced and finished and just
said i
love this song but this does not need to
come out nobody needs to hear this
i just need to know who's saying that or
is that a record label saying that
that's me luckily i am my record label
now so that's something
hi so it's thank you
and that's i think that's honestly the
scariest part because
i love i love input i think in the past
i've looked to input for approval and
i had to re-adjust that understanding of
of the people whose opinion i really do
value
around me and my capabilities of saying
i appreciate that
i i'm going to trust my gut on this
because i believe in this
because the times in the past that i
have trust me like i'm i love
i love telling this story because i love
other creatives being encouraged by
this but i remember there was a song
called i went crazy that i put out that
was one of our biggest hits it was a
massive pop crossover and
um i remember turning that song into the
label and i couldn't get anybody's
reaction i couldn't get anybody to react
to it you know
we were talking about singles we were
talking about the next project and i was
like i think this
is one of our big songs and at the time
for context
i didn't believe that i was capable
because i'm so close to all of these
songs or my children
um you know i didn't believe that i was
capable of picking a single because i'm
i'm you know inherently biased um i i
didn't trust my my instincts based on my
study of what was working at the time
and i also believed that that's what
made a hit
but i i stuck i stuck my neck out for
this song and
and um i called the guy i was pr that
was producing the song with me
or we were working on other things and
we snuck it in
to a budget to a timeline without
anybody knowing and we finished the song
we played it for the label and they're
like
holy crap that's our next single and you
know that's happened a few times i've
called a few a few songs out and i only
say that because i think
those are lessons that i have to remind
myself
of to trust in your gut and trust in
your instinct the scariest thing to
answer your question
finally but the scariest thing is is you
know
when you're used to having a team that
says this is going to work or this is
you know or this is the single or this
is the thing um
and now you're the one having to trust
your gut and trust your instinct
uh i don't know why i keep removing
myself now that i'm in this position
um i have to really trust my gut and
each other as my instinct and so far
um you know and and also i i want to
have the right people around me that i
can that i can trust as well
you know to uh to call me up or come
call me out you know
what's your relationship to um
vulnerability
in your music i feel like it's pretty
good
um i pour a lot of it i pour a lot of
myself into
to what i write and and what i put out
and and also the stories that i tell
about it um
um i'm
i'm renegotiating my relationship with
you know what parts of my story i give
away
i think you know there was a
relationship that was very pulling it
back
well not i wouldn't say pulling it back
i would say
there are certain things that i want to
i want to protect from my personal self
i pour my entire life story into these
songs and there's some things i'm i'm
okay with there's most things i'm okay
with the entire world knowing
there's some things that i don't feel
like um
you know some things i don't
want to share some things i don't feel
like are appropriate to share
you know there's there's certain aspects
of
of a song that i released recently that
aren't at all about what people think
that it's about but that's okay because
the song means something different for
them
and that's what i want i i you know i go
through these experiences
i live through them i find a way to talk
about them in a song and then i give
them away
i want other people to take you know
ownership with it that said
i'm i i feel if anything i feel like i
overshare
because i do share a lot of um my
personal life and also just my struggles
my
different things with you know whether
it be like anxiety um
you know different sort of like mild
forms of
uh i always feel guilty saying
depression which i know sounds dumb
but um i'm happy to share those things
i'm happy to share my my human
experience with the world because i
think that's what
that's that's part of what makes my art
you know that is
my art have you realized or been
identified in any way to be like a
really
like a deep empath do you realize that
you absorb people's energy
yeah for sure for
sure i've learned i've learned that
recently
yeah it's and i think that's one of the
things that drove me to songwriting was
i have to
have a place i have to have a place to
put this you know and i have to
make these things um yeah i just have to
put them somewhere there has to be an
outlet yeah
how has knowing that shifted like even
the people does it change the people you
spend time with or what you do
um just because i know that like from
friends that have this ability like
have anxiety which is taking on emotions
and you know that's one of the ways that
it happens it also can come from
ruminating on
things for too long and kind of letting
yourself spiral
but but just you know large groups or
you know certain people certain dynamics
have you seen
you know with you know moving obviously
that feels good to you i'm curious what
if that's part of the learning
about yourself yeah
yes let me read myself i'm gonna read my
my own body and listen to my myself you
know
um and to pay attention to when i'm in a
situation that i
i feel anxious or um
nervous energy bad energy about or just
you know not great energy
um and learning how to try to sort of
take breaks and and give myself what i
need and feed myself
uh because it's really easy to continue
to feed this i like i said i love what i
do so it's easy for me to
to excuse giving and giving and giving
and giving
um until i've got nothing left to give
you know
and especially you know not to keep
going back to
the past year but we've all experienced
versions of this
um my version is you know i didn't have
touring i didn't have that thing to to
continue to fill my tank and i kept
emptying my tank to make music and to
you know do interviews and do other
things and
um realized how low and depleted i was
[Music]
but yes it has changed how i spend time
with people and how i prioritize
my own time versus my time that i give
to
the people around me do you find that
when you
are more in that space of um
feeling more that you write more
sometimes some i've had to get better
better journaling i think for a long
time i excused
writing as journaling and it is and it
can be and it has been
but it's not always you are inherent you
are editing you are making something fit
into
four lines eight lines three lines of
pre-chorus a chorus
you're simplifying a lot of things
to make it into a song that works for a
lot of people so it's not really proper
journaling you leave a lot out
um so i've had to get better properly
journaling and and really
um finding a place where all of it can
can be put on paper
have i mean have you had some pretty
cathartic sort of
breakthroughs in this deeper level of
journaling because you know
i ask about vulnerability in your music
and yeah it's there but clearly there
was still more to be had
if you allowed yourself to go there
speaking from experience so it's not
like i'm i mean like i've literally had
breakdowns breakthroughs call them what
you want but it fits
like they're they're they're very
emotional yeah
no for sure and also learning how to
journal too because when you're a song
like you train i train myself so for so
long to be a better songwriter
um you have to undo so many of those
things to be a better journalist
to be a better journal whatever to write
to do better
journaling and that makes sense because
you're putting a pen to paper to write a
song you're putting a pen to paper to
journal so they feel
you know uh sort of reflexively very
similar but the
space that you're entering is very
different yeah i have to
like i have to go to a location to
journal
um it's really difficult for me to share
your tips because there's a lot of
people that this could be very helpful
for
yeah well i had to like i had to find
new places
that aren't associated with um
you know with music i've also
been able to really reassociate
certain places with journaling like i
i've chosen to
uh go to places that maybe i'm scared to
go to because they hold a certain memory
i love going there and journaling and
sort of re-evaluating
my relation because it i'm i feel better
and like i
i i get to actually process what those
feelings are
i get to put them in a journal in an
entry um
and all of a sudden those places become
healing places for me all the places
that
that is always kind of a goal of mine if
there is a place that has a bad
um connection for me or connection to a
bad
emotion it i sort of see it as a
challenge
i need to go there i need to you know
whether it be journal or just like kind
of
meditate in a way um
i i love going there reevaluating
so that those places become my favorite
places and places that actually
are you doing this all on your own or do
you have a therapist i mean like i had
people at one point so
like no i get to work with an incredible
um therapist who um
actually designs
one of my favorite sort of intensives
that i've also been to
um so i feel like i've got access to
like
a professor of sorts and that's amazing
yeah so i'm really grateful that not
only that i you know i i
did the intensive which i've wanted to
do for several years um
but it's just so easy to say well i
don't have time or i
like i don't want to i don't want to
give up a week of my time because my
team needs me for the
it's such a dumb excuse but that's the
one i used for a long time and this year
was kind of like well i don't have any
more excuses and i need to do this and
so yeah have you heard of the uh have
you ever heard of um
it's making me think of like hoffman
have you ever heard of the hoffman
institute it's like there's i think two
locations
but it's a week long where you like dive
into the
uh dynamics and sort of emotions of
childhood because
i don't know if you figured it out yet
but it literally all is before you're
six years old pretty much
yeah yeah have you figured that out yeah
that was a pretty wild one for me
um and and dealing with that was was
incredible it's so funny how long it
took me
uh to sort of face that because we knew
like walking into it like that's where
we needed to start
but i i fought it and i i walked my way
backwards from here to then
like over the course of several days and
uh was finally
it was very very clear to me what i was
running from and what i was scared to
sort of like face
you know head-on um so yeah i actually
haven't heard of
hoffman what's what's it called hoffman
i think it's called the hoffman
institute or hoffman process
i think it's maybe the hopkins process
but there's a few different kinds i mean
there's like
that's like a really famous one for
being like a week long you can't you go
you can't use your phone you can't work
out
you literally like can't do anything
that you would lean on
i almost went but then covet happened
and i couldn't go
and um and i remember like for myself it
was like you can't work out and i
remember thinking phone who cares and i
was like work out what yeah
why is that so bad and i was like i
probably have some kind of an
attachment to that as being like an
outlet or a coping mechanism
um but you can't do anything um but
those processes are so
i mean it's like i've been thinking
lately that the um
the human experience is really
simple yet complicated or
and complicated because it's simple in
that
everything in your reality is is kind of
reflecting you back to you
or showing you you through like a
trigger
or through a judgment or through
somebody else projecting
and how that makes it's all information
about you yet it's complicated because
you can't see you
you need other people to see you because
since it's an original sort of like
root programming you can't know the
program it's already there
like the program is already installed
and so you can't tell what program
you're running because it's on autopilot
and so you're like oh wow you need all
and you get all this feedback from other
people it's really you
experiencing yourself wow
yeah that's a great way to put that yeah
that makes a lot and that makes a lot of
sense that's totally applicable
i relate to that but yeah that makes a
lot of sense
i i do it it one of one of my biggest
breakthroughs was
um was when we had the conversation of
um you know like you just try
i just shrugged off like what do you
love about yourself it's like what what
what
what that how how do i even what what
does it mean
and uh and we had to again kind of
reverse engineer into that as well
you know okay we'll pick pic pick your
you know
your favorite person someone you love
deeply what what what is
it that you love about them and you you
name those things and those top five
things
are actually things that you you you see
in that
person because you see it in yourself um
and that was a wild like groundbreaking
thing for me uh because i was like holy
crap
okay i get it that makes a lot of sense
and and the negative is true as well you
know
that's really helped me because any time
i'm i'm
i'm annoyed i'm saying this knowing that
i'm in the room with someone who's
experienced me at my best at my absolute
worst
but um but it has
really helped me understand people who
you know who i have a hard time getting
along with you know or have a hard time
working with
or um or
i mean just just people in general like
it you know
if there's something that i that bothers
me about them chances are it's just
because it bothers me about myself it's
something that i really want to work on
so
yeah or something you deny that's so
it's the common one like when we judge
like when i judge something in someone
i'm like
oh yeah that's because i'd never allow
myself to do that or act like that
or whatever it may be like it's a denial
that's like
totally where my judgments come in i
mean there's a lot of ways to unpack it
for sure but
it's it's it's a fascinating thing the
human experience is so fascinating and
so
you know i i think that while i know
we're not talking directly about music
but
it's this depth that creates it
right it's this depth that um gives you
oh like a need almost really right like
it's there
it's therapeutic it's an outlet it's a
release
and so what do you think it is that um
and saying that it makes me think about
hits and hit songs and you talking
earlier about
ones that you know you push through
because you really believed in them
and you know can you
feel it is there
is there a feeling or is there some
awareness to
when you've created something that's
really special
you definitely feel it it's hard to
quantify
um which is i think the challenge of of
our job
but a hundred percent you you know when
you've
communicated something to someone very
well
you know when you've um
i think i mean i guess i was speaking
generally i think when you're talking to
a friend
you sort of walk away um like you've
spoken all of your truth
you know and i think songs can can be
the same way even
even considering the fact that we're
editing right um you still have a
purpose for the song you start i start
out with the title i love
starting with titles and i've got you
know
thousands of voice memos of you know
music
things that happen on a piano or a
guitar or something i sing in the car
and and i don't surprisingly have a lot
of
lyrical things but i think that's
because i kind of trained myself when i
first started songwriting because i knew
you know
i have a scheduled songwriting session
with someone at 11 o'clock on tuesday
and i'm gonna have to recreate the
feeling i'm feeling on 3am on saturday
so i kind of got to a place where i like
sort of and that's that makes a lot of
sense
in the context of things but i held on
to a lot of emotions because i knew i'd
have to tap into them at some point so
um so it's sort of it starts with the
title and the title
is literally meant to be a trigger funny
enough
um and it sends you back there and and i
think um the songs that are written by
myself happen
when they're supposed to happen they
happen in the moment but the songs that
i've written with other people
you know they start by yourself and then
you continue them when you're in the
room with them and when you're scheduled
to be there so i think
knowing that and having those songs
there's a
feeling of totality and completion when
you walk away and you know that you've
shared all of your truth because
not only you're not just sculpting a
song you're expressing and
by by nature the the more tapped in you
are to that expression
the more honest you are with that
expression and the more of your truth
you allow
you can say a word
it's not the same as singing a word and
when you sing a word
um if you're tapped into it you can feel
it on the other end
of the line you can you can hear and
subconsciously we all know this that's
why we're drawn to certain songs and
we're not drawn to certain songs certain
songs feel calculated to us we don't
know
why they feel calculated but they do
they don't have an emotion on the other
end
and certain people you know um
can it can sing the simplest line and
you just
break you know or um or they can
take you know or you know there's pure
joy in certain
songs that feel like dance songs and
there's also a reason why dance songs
you know sometimes these happy songs
only last so long with us because
there's only so much of that that's
actually there so you know i think for
me
my feeling when i know that i've really
tapped into a song i leave the studio
and i just feel like
um it's not it's not purely about like
just me saying my truth
i know that by saying by being fully
present by being fully truthful
i also gave the words the color that
they needed
and and i was able to supply the emotion
behind that one note or that note was
chosen because there was a motion behind
it it wasn't just we strung
these words together cleverly and then
we figured out how they fit in an eight
bar phrase
um everything went into it and you sort
of walk away and it's honestly kind of
emotionally exhausting
when i leave a session that i feel like
i've done well i'm definitely just like
my day's done yeah
that makes perfect sense though i mean
i'm curious how
about um religion because i've heard you
talk about religion a fair amount
religion versus spirituality
or and spirituality and so the things
that you're saying really make me
feel like you know there's uh
in the quantum field there's or in
consciousness there's an
there's a frequency there's an energy to
truth
it holds a resonance it has it res
truth resonates with with someone with
you
than with me and so or the listener
and so you know i'm curious how
religion has played into your life
because that all feels kind of spiritual
and now that you're out in la it's all
spirituality out there so
i mean i lived in l.a for a hot second
and uh
and i'm i'm like a i'm a spiritual nerd
so like i've got crystal balls behind me
and you know you can't see all my
woo-woo stuff i put my crystals out last
night under the full moon so
you know that's where i lean um but you
know i've sure had my fair experience
with with religion as well
um but but that's sort of what it feels
like to me is that there's
and i've thought this for a long time
that there's like a frequency or there's
an
energy or a or a collective conscious
awareness to
truth i believe that
i think honestly my relationship with
religion
is was the driving
factor
to me and my relationship with
spirituality now
um because i really struggled with
certain aspects of religion um
especially anytime anything's monetized
you just by nature it's flawed
and you mean you mean the basket that
goes around with putting money in it
it could be the it could be the basket i
you know i had a priest i went to
catholic churches a lot when i was a kid
that's all we
i went to catholic church as a kid and
you grew up in louisiana
yeah and there was this one priest that
was constantly
you know he'd he'd deliver a 10 minute
sermon
and then he'd spend 30 minutes with a
powerpoint telling you how they were
struggling to pay for the church
and i think that's when it became very
clear and i was like 12.
but i think that's when i started
disconnecting
religion from spirituality and somewhere
and i was somewhere in the middle for a
long time and then i realized what i'm
trying to find is spirituality what i'm
trying to understand the spirituality
what i want
what i'm craving is a connection
with an understanding of spirituality um
and it's come in
multiple forms and i think from
traveling the world and meeting people
from you know from very different walks
of life
it's opened my eyes in a beautiful way
to understanding
um that there's a lot more to understand
and that is going to be a lifelong
journey and a lifelong search for me and
i
um and i love the the i love
the adventure of coming to understand
that and understanding all the different
perspectives if there's if there's a
faith that i don't understand i long to
understand it as best i can
um and i think it's it's really allowed
me to
to to seek truth and not just believe
i love the uh the religion
maybe it's just because i saw it on
instagram somebody made it up i don't
know i don't care
um but it's omnism which is the belief
is that you don't believe in any one
religion but that there's truth in all
of them
and i think that's true in fact i would
say that's actually the truth in general
about mankind and the human
and the human experience is that at a
fundamental level
the core of what is desired or wanted
or what feels good or what we're all
aspiring to or trying for or reaching
for
is the same so it's kind of like
religion of fundamentally
when you look at sort of the core values
of all of them it's like the same
it's kind of treat others as you would
you know treat
treat others as you would want as you
would treat yourself although actually
the problem is we
treat ourselves like [ __ ] usually like
have you ever listened to your inner
monologue for a second and gone
wow i would never be friends with that
person which is why the real work is
actually the inside job because once you
fix the relationship with the words that
you say to yourself
you start reflecting that back out into
the world and i think that that's sort
of like
and for me that's a little bit where
religion loses it is it's like you go
to somewhere you talk to someone you
hand over your
i'm you're like oh forgive me it's like
forgive yourself
like the inside job it's like you've
gotta you've gotta you've gotta do the
inside work
nothing outside of you i mean it can
help for sure i'm not saying it's all
bad
i just think that it's um it's not the
ultimate cure-all it's more
band-aid-oriented in my mind and so
um you know spirituality definitely
is a sort of leans in that do you feel
have you felt
a shift from like towards being
more of an inside job yeah i think
you know the two reactions because i
have a lot of friends who are very very
devout in their religion and i think
uh when we have these conversations i
find it really interesting if you can
remove
the guilt of someone you know
if you could if you can appreciate the
truth of
appreciating truth um and rather than if
if you you know appreciate the truth
about this faith then that
counters your own faith as long like
that's
that's where things in my opinion get
you know you get the hiccup and i i do
also believe um because because
we are seeking truth in in as just as
humans as people
right um and and there are so many
truths
and and all of that and and i have a lot
of friends who are did you say i'm
nism i've actually been looking for the
word somebody yeah i have a lot of
friends who
who are that way and i love that and i
um
and i also think that is a challenge
um the messaging
i do struggle with that when you know
you're you're
we're you know preached to
about how we're created and how
wonderful
we are and then we're told that when
we're
broken uh we have to go somewhere else
to to sort of
fix it and that's not to say that you
know prayer isn't isn't
i think the messaging is slightly off
you know that
um that other people are supposed to fix
us or
that we even need to be fixed in in
and that sentence is so flawed in so
many ways
um and i i do have a hard time when it's
um when it's when you're made to believe
that you
um that it isn't already in
you and you weren't created with the
good that you're seeking
you know um and that you know that that
when you are sort of
depleted uh that you have to go to a
place
um i i i think that messaging is flawed
and i think we
um we kind of live in on i mean my
experience in society currently is that
we're made to believe that and that's
not to say that
this is really this is really tricky
because um
because i do believe in asking for help
and i believe in
um you know and i preach like just like
we go to the gym we should be going to a
therapist every week you don't have to
be broken you don't have to have
anything to fix
you're just you're improving all the
things that you have inside of you
there are so many people who have helped
me
um and so many people that i i i i need
to to help me but they're helping me
find myself they're helping me
yeah uh see the things that i'm trying
to to see in myself that i really want
to see in myself
cause again we need someone else to help
reflect
us back to us right
um i'm curious if you feel like
in your i don't know if it ends up being
i'm curious if it's like a song
is a sort of uh a transitional or
alchemizing sort of emotion and it's
like uh
within that held within that one song or
or does this end up happening
in albums like can you look at an album
over time and go
oh that's when i was blah and that's
when i was there
and that's when i was right and whatever
was going on in your
reality in your world emotionally um
can you identify it through the album or
is it more more in songs
both um i think certain
because every i i
very often talk about my life in album
cycles and i
i think part of it is is in the past
has been you know identity and
so much of myself and my music but i
also think part of it is
they represented a chapter um
would you in charge would you indulge us
and uh
go through like the albums and just get
go like okay here was
here's where i was at here and here and
here and here's where i'm at now and
then
you know futurecast for me yeah that's
my favorite thing to do are you kidding
me how much time do you have i'll do
this
oh my god i love futurecasting i am so
attached to outcomes you have no idea
i'm like i have all my dreams laid out
that's like
and they're great i'm gonna make them
happen and then i realize i need to let
go of things but anyway
um yeah please i'd love to hear that
because i think that
the the growth cycle is so fascinating
and so
also admirable to say that growth so
many people don't
i mean you know i mean it's a hard thing
it's a hard thing and some people don't
have the means and some people don't
have the sight
yeah um
well i mean going going backwards
i think i you know i use i use this in
this sort of imagery a lot but i love
talking about legos because
um you know you you you buy this thing
you got a box you have the instructions
you built the thing and then
i think the most beautiful part is when
you realize i've got all these pieces i
can do whatever i want i can make
whatever i want out of it you know
and i have all these pieces and i'm sort
of i i see
myself in my music like that um with
every success that i've had
i'm taking forward the lesson of what's
what's possible
not just what we accomplished but what
can be accomplished
um from from a beginning to you know
from a vision of something you want to
to getting there you know i saved before
you saw us
on the care underwater i had a note when
i moved to
to nashville whatever that was 11 12
years ago um
just a note and at the time i would go
in google earth
on my sort of days that i wasn't writing
or making music
and i went to every major city and i
found every arena
and i wikipedia searched what that arena
could hold the end stage concert
i had the capacities i knew where the
loading docks were i knew where the
buses parked
and i had this for like 120 arenas
around the country
and i played 95 of them and i knew every
single one of them
uh when we played them on the carrie
underwood tour because i had i had gone
and i had dreamed it up and i also
knew what the set was going to look like
before we built it and you mentioned
this thing mother
i didn't know that that's what i was
doing i thought it was crazy like i
thought like these you know these dream
boards that i had like the fact that i
would spend so much time
you know envisioning in my head like
what the production would look like
three years before i could even afford a
production um i had no idea what i was
doing i just thought i was dreaming of
something that made me happier
um i didn't know that i was actually
just like
driving towards that thing some
yeah so it i'm really grateful that i
got to experience that
so quickly and take that as a as a
future truth not just
a dream or an idea not just something
somebody had told me but i can actually
speak to it now i can say no
it's funny because i didn't believe i
didn't even believe in the science
behind it i didn't even know the science
behind it i thought i was crazy i
thought at some point
some really smart therapist would tell
me you know you should really probably
stop
doing that it's not good for i had no
idea that it was actually really good
for me and it worked i watched it work i
watched
it happen and i've watched it happen
many times since then i was gonna say
and you could use it not only do you
know and have sight to the
what happened but you can go oh wow this
is a tool yeah it's a brilliant tool
um and now i'm kind of like okay what do
i what do i want to build
like i've i've modeled after you know
other people's success for for so long
and i've done versions of my own
versions of it
but now now i'm kind of like okay what's
the what's the
big picture thing that i know will play
to my strengths and
how can i like give all of me because i
you know
um i part of me i love producing other
artists as well
i love working with new artists i love
working with new artists
um you know i
i'm grateful to be able to give my
perspective but i'm also just like
you know one of the things that dan huff
did for me was the mirror he told me he
was like i'm
just here to be a mirror so you can kind
of see your music
through somebody else's lives which is
full circle that we're kind of speaking
in those terms now but
um he did that and i love i love doing
that with other artists and and new
artists
sort of finding their sound and finding
their voice and um
and that's something i'm really
passionate about and love to do um
that's not you know i i can't i don't
want to let that take away from my own
artistry
i'm selfish but i want to build that as
part of my career i want that to be part
of what i do and help
you know young new artists develop their
thing and find their thing i get the
fact i can feel that it's like future
casting is far more fun
and i think that forget it we don't need
to worry about the past then let's do
that let's keep going
because i think that that's you know so
powerful
and um you know you're calling it in
and that's like i mean honestly that's
kind of plays into a little bit of
spirituality too
where you know there's more power in
your reality than you realize and the
power of the mind and power of words and
you should probably write a song called
abracadabra um
but um you know you know in ancient
times i mean abracadabra was like
you know the word said became spells
like they're
powerful powerful things coming out of
your mouth um
but i think that uh i think it's a great
lesson for people
because yes sometimes people stumble
onto it and sometimes people haven't
even
haven't stumbled onto it or don't
believe in it and
um and i think this could fit into that
context a little bit religiously of like
you know
predetermined you know sort of course in
life and life is happening to you
um instead of happening for you and
showing you you
and giving you the power to make changes
um but what other you talked about dream
boards and
i mean i've done the same thing with
myself whether it's like i want to build
something at my house or
i want whatever it is that i want in my
world
i'll screenshot things and i'll keep
them in my phone
or you know you know yes pictures
collect them into a folder about
something i want to do
and sure enough these things become real
like you're like
look back and you can go dude it's
exactly what i was screenshotting it's
exactly the tear outside of the magazine
it's exactly
or you know exactly the person that i
literally wrote into my phone and
or wrote on a piece of paper and said i
want this to be i want
x y z a b c d e f g h exactly all the
way down and you
get them and you're like holy [ __ ]
so what other dream board stuff have
come true
have come true um it's really funny
because early on
it was a lot of tour buses private
planes
and cars because i'm a car guy i well
okay
you can't say that i can't say i don't
feel like i could say that in this
context but
normally that's something i feel very
confident in talking about i don't at
the moment but
you could um i don't know about cars i
know that might shock you but i don't
know about cars
i um i love design i
love um i love intentionality i love
just the thought
behind design i love i also think you
know
not currently so much but i love the era
study of eras i should say where cars
were art
they had to appeal to us emotionally um
and so i love the cars that i can feel
that with
to in my opinion one of the most iconic
things is this shelby cobra
and that's like that's something i
really really want um the only
one that i like it's the only old car i
like
i don't really care i like new cars but
i mostly don't even care about cars
but is the one did you have a shelby
cobra in your music video
yes i did yes i did um
yeah but even that said like i love
driving and i know this could be
sacrilegious a lot of people
listening to this but i don't want one
with the v8 because i didn't get to
really experienced or yeah an eight
seller i didn't really get to experience
the car
in the context that i was driving it i
want something that i can actually have
a lot of fun with
um and i i've but
i guess my point is i had cars on my
dream board and i've
you know owned or driven almost all of
them
at this point um and when i say all of
them it's not like it's a crazy
you know like i've driven the
lamborghinis and the ferraris have not
owned that's not a thing that that makes
me happy
you know um but i have driven them and
i've had a blast
um i've owned the more practical
versions of them because i can enjoy
them i can
i can look at it every day and go okay i
feel good about my
my my money my spending those kind of
things and i'm still 100.
you can go buy a sports car if you want
people are going to expect you to have a
sports car you're a famous musician
yeah i think more of the practicality
you know i look at like
uh the car parked next to me in the
garage right now it's this gorgeous
ferrara california not my favorite
ferrari if i'm being honest but it is
stunning
but i look at that and i think yeah but
i could have a vintage neve
console that i could not only make
records with
but i could also rent out for people to
use
and i i could look at something to make
anyway so it's just practically
but um that's fun like i'll never forget
i have the picture i thought i had it
over here i was gonna point to it but i
don't i don't think i've put it up yet
um you know i have the picture of my
first private plane ride
um and i'll just i'll never forget that
flight
because it was just like it just changed
my life like i was just like okay this
is something i gotta work towards like
this is good this is a good thing
and it's not something that happens
often but i celebrate it when it does
happen and i enjoy it when it happens
you know that is an
absolute line item in my life with my
financial about like yeah private planes
that's a must
and i know i'm like champagne problems i
get it i get it but
it's that great i mean okay we'll just
stop now this is well i think
i think that no i think the point of
this is saying you know that for a long
time was an
un imaginable dream that felt very out
of reach and even though that's not a
part of my reality
like consistently um it has happened
and it does happen every now and then
you know there have been gigs i've taken
because i got to flat private like no
shame that's why i took the gig
so you know it's just what decisions do
you want to make and what you know what
feeds
your soul and what really is a priority
and i think that's
when i realized no my priorities aren't
the buses the cars the planes my
priority is playing on the stage
and right now my my future dream board
is i'm i'm
envisioning what it's going to be like
my relationship with performing changed
when i
um went on like my major label like my
first
radio tour because um my art
approval was so important and uh
so critical to the next step and and
approval was tied to
literally everything that i wanted so my
relationship with performing changed and
i
i'm working my way back to my original
relationship and i'm very excited
you know the next time i walk on stage
um i know that i won't be there i know
it's going to take some
practices and effort but i'm very
excited to walk on stage
and and have the relationship with music
that i had when i was six years old and
seven years old
um and and just go out there and just
be me and just love i i am myself i'm
most
that's not true i am very i have myself
on stage but i also leave things out and
i also
you know all of my anxiety is wrapped
around
approval and and um and i think that
keeps me from being
uh fully present on stage so i'm excited
to to rebuild that relationship and walk
out on stage and do the same shows i've
done
um as my full self
yeah you know you're a virgo right
and um do you know what the nature of
virgo is
um i've heard different versions of it
from different people but yes
essentially yes so you're saying that
you want approval it's like the problem
with
virgo so i took a couple levels of
astrology so
i have some experience and knowledge um
not no way expert but i have some
and um my son sits in the sixth house
which is the house of virgo and so i'm
an aries son but it sits in the sixth
house which is important it's a it's a
critical element of the chart
um but yours your your son is in virgo
and virgos are
so i know it that's why i'm speaking to
it is because i know this
and i have the same like i had a total
meltdown last year
when i was asked to uh write down
when i knew i'd made it or what i was
proud of
and i was like i can't like i don't know
did i
and like ability to be able to see
what's actually been done
is like a blind spot and so
it's like you want the wanting that sort
of approval
is um illusionary a little bit because
you never end up feeling it is you had
to come from yourself
and so um anyway i just i
mentioned when i was reading up and
looking at a few odds and ends about you
um i i wondered if you were a virgo and
i saw that you were and i was like oh
man i'll have to tell them it's such a
it's a tough one because virgos are so
detail-oriented
they're artistic they're they're
analytical they're
um practical um they're
high achievers um health conscious
there's like a lot of
great things about a virgo but the
problem is is there your ability to be
able to actually
see what you've done and take ownership
and own the accomplishments is
is like very very hard to access
i connect with that i totally connect
with that
yeah um so i
i really i'm giving you
sight you've accomplished so much like
you
and as i said it early on about having
your own identity within music and
not necessarily being able to put your
finger on the genre or exactly what it
is
is speaking to the talent that you have
because otherwise if you don't have
if it's not coming from in you you have
to fit into a box like
you've got to find a box right um so
you've you've i mean i could play wanted
on end over and over again
such a good song and you've created some
really great music and
um and so i think that and just your
your your level of um vulnerability
and honesty is so rare like thank you
for this conversation because
you're giving a lot of people a lot of a
lot of ways to see themselves
and relate and also i think what it
speaks
volumes to is the quality and the
integrity of your music
i sincerely appreciate that thank you
thank you
so i'm giving you all the credit you can
have it
thank you thank you i know you won't
probably take it all
but i sincerely appreciate that honestly
thank you
thank you yeah because i did i also
love the application of the more you can
give yourself credit for the more you
can give other people
credit for as well you know totally
well congrats on everything and you've
got new music out
and cool new uh music videos with shelby
cobras in it
and um and uh you know a new
new site new views not only
externally but internally so you're
doing the work man good job
thank you thank you so much and thank
you for the conversation i thoroughly
thoroughly enjoyed this thanks everybody
for listening to the pretty intense
podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today
and you want to hear more please click
on the subscribe button